depuis leurs résidences cossues sur les
pentes du mont royal de riches familles
exerce une grande influence sur la
politique canadienne
on y trouve deux des plus importants
collecteurs de fonds du parti libéral du
canada
l'ex-sénateur les aux cobras et le
milliardaire stephen bronfman a joué un
rôle clé dans la victoire de justin
trudeau est ce qu'on est tous fiers
les libéraux ont promis d'appuyer la
classe moyenne et s'attaquer aux paradis
fiscaux à combattre l'évasion fiscale et
l'évitement fiscal international
mais les pins les spurs belle que
stephen bronfman et leo kolber de grands
argentiers des libéraux était
étroitement lié à une fiducie des
caraïbes la fuite contient des documents
confidentiels qui semble indiquer selon
des experts en fiscalité
le recours à des échappatoires fiscales
et paiement déguisé et transactions
douteuses des millions de dollars
ont-ils échappait au fisc canadien il
sont camouflés réalité
1996 à ottawa au musée des beaux-arts du
canada et journalistes assistent au
dévoilement de toiles de maîtres
impressionnistes comme monnaie un don
d'une valeur d'au moins 10 millions de
dollars à l'avant scène des membres de
la célèbre famille bronfman qui a légué
ses toiles de maîtres au musée dont
steven graffman à droite et son père
charles
mais l'image de grands philanthropes des
branchements en a pris un coup
enfin selon le rapport accablant publié
quelques semaines auparavant
bonsoir labs et messieurs on comprends
que ça puisse choquer les contribuables
canadiens
il ya deux fiducie familiale ce serait
celle des brunchs une qui ont permis de
transférer deux milliards 2 milliards de
dollars sans payer d'impôt vert des
états unis le vérificateur général du
canada denis desautels révélait que de
riches contribuables avaient transféré
des milliards dans des fiducie aux états
unis sans payer d'impôt sur le gain en
capital
si on veut on voit des choses qui
viennent clé une érosion l'assiette
fiscale département dès maintenant à la
retraite denis desautels a accepté de
parler de son enquête sans nous
confirmer l'identité des contribuables
visés
il n'a jamais divulguer leurs noms selon
lui il s'agit d'un cas important car des
centaines de millions de dollars en
impôts ont possiblement échapper au fisc
avec la bénédiction même de revenu
canada saura soit à nous intriguer
ça semble aller à l'arrière de
l'intention de la loi
les fonctionnaires de revenu canada
avait pourtant refusé d'autoriser la
manoeuvre fiscale des branchements
mais la famille avait laissé entendre
qu'elle contourneraient les
fonctionnaires responsables et qu'elle
irait plus haut pour obtenir une
décision favorable
c'est pas la façon de régler les
dossiers
peu de temps après la haute direction de
revenu canada a fait marche arrière
elle a donné son accord au plus mal sans
qu'aucune note n'était prise pour
expliquer ce revirement de dernière
minute ce sont des décisions extrêmement
importantes pour précédent que sacré
pour tous les contribuables
donc on aurait cru que le raisonnement
soit complètement établi puis documenté
et c'était pas gagné c'était pas donc ça
c'est une chose de cette crise qui de
façon très sévère à ottawa le
gouvernement libéral a tiré à boulet
rouge sur le vérificateur général
plus encore on lui fait grief d'avoir
tenté de substituer son opinion à celle
de revenu canada mais l'opposition en a
profité pour faire pression sur le
gouvernement
c'est des milliards et chapeau
l'effet draguer mais casser des
milliards il ya un problème majeur c'est
le gouvernement agit pas rapidement à la
fin de la conférence de presse au musée
des beaux arts d'ottawa un charles
bronfman contrarié a fait face aux
questions des journalistes
c'était un épisode embarrassant pour les
bronfman une des plus riches familles du
québec et brafman ont fait fortune grâce
à la distillerie seagram et à des
projets de développement immobilier
un des amis les plus proches des banques
même et lie au club pendant des
décennies leo kolber à aider à gérer
lempire brafman ans dirige entre autres
leur société d'investissement claridge à
montréal il est le parrain de steven
brafman il a été nommé sénateur par
pierre trudeau on le voit ici avec
trudeau père et le jeune justin lors du
match d'ouverture la saison des expos en
le sénateur courbet était aussi un
collecteur de fonds importants du parti
libéral la rencontre privée qui avaient
été cachés aux médias cette année il a
organisé les soirées de financement
privé controversé à sa résidence de
westmount offrant accès au chef du parti
et à ses ministres
mais loin des caméras et des regards
indiscrets
le sénateur colbert a fait créer une
fiducie dans un des paradis fiscaux les
plus opaques de la planète des îles
caïmans
on
aux îles caïmans des sociétés fiducie ne
paient pas d'impôts et profite du secret
bancaire
mais la nouvelle fuite des périodes as
people exposé au grand jour des milliers
de documents confidentiels de la fiducie
kober mais cette ut majeur est tellement
essentiel au débat il ya eu beaucoup de
documents ses poursuites et évidemment
et il est beaucoup question ici de
masquer la réalité de faire des belles
façades cette fiducie a été constituée
pour le bénéfice des enfants du sénateur
kober dont jonathan qui allait déménager
à l'extérieur du canada pour gérer des
entreprises des branches même les
documents nous montre que ce sont les
bronfman qui ont fourni la majeure
partie des fonds initiaux à la fiducie
kober une fiducie étrangères c'est comme
si vous donniez votre fortune dans ce
cas-ci des fonds provenant de montréal à
quelqu'un d'autre
le fiduciaire qui situé aux et cayman
charles brafman a transféré près de neuf
millions de dollars américains à la
fiducie puis quelques années plus tard
son fils steven a fourni cinq millions
de dollars
tout ça sous forme de prêt qui ont par
la suite été remboursés
c'est le fiduciaire aux îles caïmans qui
est responsable de gérer cette fortune
pour ne pas être assujettis aux lois
canadiennes
toutes les décisions de la fiducie
doivent être réellement prise par le
fiduciaire osé le caïman et non pas au
canada mais était ce le cas avec nos
collègues chefs de state et du toronto
star
nous avons montré de nombreux documents
confidentiels la fiducie kober à la
professeur de droit fiscal et ancienne
candidate libérale marwari ski on y
découvre qu'un conseiller financier
travaillant à montréal devait approuver
les transactions de la fiducie
on se rend compte que la gestion d avron
se fasse pas mal à montréal que les
décisions sont prises à montréal donc
toute la question du contrôle de la
fiducie est ici et non pas à l'étranger
donc qu' on peut dire que c'est une
résidence de fait canadienne
la conséquence est que la finition
serait assujettie aux règles fiscales
canadiennes
une note interne montre à quel point les
conseillers fiscaux des famille bronfman
et kobe voulait bini mise et l'apparence
de liens avec le canada
ils ont exigé que soit modifié la nature
d'un paiement de plus de 80 mille
dollars versés par la fiducie ou
conseiller financier de montréal afin
qu'il y ait un lien formel de moins avec
des entités situées à l'extérieur des
îles caïmans la boxe de saft
l'expert américain john mica watch a
analysé les documents secrets de la
fiducie corbeau la fuite révèle
plusieurs autres manoeuvres comptables
ayant pour effet de masquer la réalité
selon les experts en 2004 les branches
mais non transférer 4 millions de
dollars américains à la fiducie kober
sous forme de prêt en imputant des
intérêts selon des documents
confidentiels
il est clair que le bénéficiaire
jonathan coben ne s'attendait pas à
devoir payer des intérêts pour régler le
problème des hauts dirigeants de chrage
à montréal ont alors suggéré que
jonathan kober facture à claridge des
frais pour services rendus du même
montant au sein de près que les intérêts
qu'ils avaient été imputés à la fiducie
courbure avec clairement quels aliments
qui ne font que jamais aucun risque ont
été rendus
on fait un paiement compensatoire et c
est fait sponsoring et coups droits côté
créé en réponse à nos questions
les avocats de jonathan courbure sont
catégoriques aucune facture n'a été
envoyée et rien n'a été payée distille
pourtant un ancien vice-président de
claridge nous a confirmé au téléphone
que je n'attaque aubert avait bel et
bien facturé claridge pour des services
que ce soit la fiducie kober où les
nombreux autres fiducie met sur pied
dans les paradis fiscaux le secret règne
il est bien difficile
le fisc canadien de savoir ce qui s'y
passe
[Musique]
pendant des décennies des fortunes
canadiennes se sont envolés vers les
paradis fiscaux comme fiducie mis sur
pied aux îles caïmans par le sénateur
canadien lee au cover est financé en
partie par des prêts de charles et
stephen bronfman
ceux qui tuent seaal éventuellement
détenir plus de 60 millions de dollars
américains d'actifs
[Musique]
en pleine période de compressions
budgétaires vers la fin des années 90 le
ministère des finances du canada a
annoncé vouloir récupérer une partie des
fortunes classé sous les palmiers dans
son budget de 1999 le gouvernement
libéral avait inclus des mesures visant
à mettre fin à l'utilisation abusive des
fiducie étrangères par de riches
canadiens
judy wasylycia lice était député néo
démocrate à la chambre des communes
elle a milité pendant des années contre
les paradis fiscaux atteinte gravement
atteint est beau tout chaud concern
about échoue par endroits d'une afrique
c'est qu'après l'arrivée des
conservateurs au pouvoir que projet de
loi visant les fiducie dans les paradis
fiscaux a été déposé à la chambre des
communes le projet de loi a reçu l'appui
unanime tous les partis y compris des
libéraux en 10 15 heures
les nouvelles lois qu'ils n'avaient pas
encore reçu l'assentiment du sénat
allait affecter de nombreuses fiducie
déjà existantes dans les paradis fiscaux
co inc lors des audiences d'un comité du
sénat des fiscalistes ont lancé une
attaque en règle contre le projet de loi
des plus intransigeants était stephen
rigby un avocat du cabinet davies ward
fixe son cabinet davies ward et celui
qui représente entre autres les familles
brosnan et kober en fin de compte le
sénat qui était encore contrôlé par les
libéraux n'a jamais ratifié le projet de
loi il est mort au feuilleton lors du
déclenchement des élections de 2008
[Musique]
puis il a fallu six autres années avant
qu'une nouvelle loi soit finalement
adopté par la chambre des communes en
même si on a des belles voir les gens
vont s'assurer de carême respecter la
loi sur papier ça prend des fois
malheureusement des fuites pour réaliser
que la réalité est tout à fait
indifférent
qu'est ce qui était écrit dans les
documents depuis qu'est-il advenu de la
fiducie kober elle a été liquidée en
2016 et les fonds étaient transférés
vers israël où vit le bénéficiaire et
fiducie jonathan kober le fils de l'ex
sénateur en réponse à nos questions
l'avocat représentant les bombes
humaines et colbert maintient que la
fiducie courbure n'a jamais été contrôlé
et géré depuis le canada
pourtant lors d'un entretien
téléphonique avec nos collègues de siby
si jonathan courbe lui-même a admis que
les décisions de fiducie était prise par
le conseiller financier montréalais
s'était lui il conseillé c'est lui qui
prenait les décisions at il dit donc là
c'est un aveu cloud sa part les
naissances ont véritablement prises
estime canada et par conséquent tout le
contrôle et la gestion de cette fille
qui pense par montréal
s'ils contrôlent la fiducie qu'aubry
était bel et bien au canada et non aux
caïmans elle pourrait devoir verser des
millions fisc canadien en impôts impayés
l'avocat de robert affirme que ses
clients ont toujours agi de façon
éthique en respectant les lois en
vigueur
aucune des transactions et entités en
question n'ont été mis sur pied pour
faire de l'évasion ou de l'évitement
fiscal dit-il stephen bronfman nuit a
été recruté par son ami justin trudeau
pour diriger sa campagne au leadership
fin est ensuite devenu le directeur de
financement du parti libéral
on savait on ne gagne pas une élection
sans fond et le premier argentine du
parti ali maire défait ça peut être
approprié à ce statique
le parti libéral du canada se distancie